We first saw him running the fence line where the horses are kept.
Yes. And then he came back later that afternoon when we were installing the swing.
I hadn't mentioned we're swingers now.
Oh.
A large portion of our community enjoys swinging.
Mainly the children traditionally, but recently we've joined a number of adults for a swing.
We've swung with each other's parents once.
How's the dog?
Oh, he was barely conscious when he first wandered over. Eyes barely open, just little slits.
The tightest little slits.
As he was losing consciousness, I began jerking him to keep him up.
Two hands at one point.
He had a fairly serious gash on his side once.
Clashed with a coyote, no doubt.
Well, if you fight one of them, you fight a bunch of them.
I was able to patch him up, but it took a lot of tender loving care.
Let's just say I've had my face in gash for the better part of three days.
Face and fingers.
I swiftly retrieved my scissors and crafted a bandage for the gash.
No one scissors like mine wife.
Well, our daughters scissor quite skillfully.
Now, credit where it's due. Our daughters learned to scissor from their mother.
Teaching our daughters to scissor has been one of the great joys of my life.
Look at me. I get wet just thinking about it.
A D for Dick.
An A for Anita.
An N for Noah.
And the tea leaves are in the shape of a dick?
Where's he now, Anita?
Is he confined?
We wrapped him in a blanket and laid him by a fire once.
Well meaning folks, just a wee bit redneck.
The children have taken quite a fondness to Sunshine.
Sunshine?
Yes, the name we've given him, if only temporarily.
We thought of calling him Monster for the sickness, living inside of him.
Monster Dyck.
And he was so thin when he first arrived. We thought of calling him Pencil.
Pencil Dyck.
We even considered naming him after Noah's late grandmother, Sarah Theresa Dyck.
STD for short.
What? Discharge? Discharge. Discharge. Discharge.
At last we settled on-
His name is-
Sunshine.
You're not supposed to give dogs human names.
We'll be sad to see him go.
I assume you's are here to take him back. Return him to his true master.
I think we're not in front of. All right. Okay.
Looks like we agree.
How would you's like to keep them?
Now, mine wife. You know, on Mennonite farms, animals fulfill only two functions t'werk and t'eat.
But Sunshine is still healing.
Joyful wife, joyful life.
Alright then, he can stay.
We'll continue to tend to him day to day.
I'm surprised that my wife didn't become a doctor, for it would seem as though she can't resist an open gash.
My husband knew I was many things when he married me, but I can assure you a gash lover was not one of them.
It's true.